good morning everyone good morning uh
the hour has come we will make a
start um welcome to this meeting of mids
District Council cabinet I'm councelor
Andy melon leader of mids District
Council I'll be chairing this
meeting May I first of all remind you of
some domestic Arrangements um please
ensure that microphones are turned off
when not in use uh that you do not
interrupt other speakers please switch
off all mobile phones or turn them to
silent I'm just reminding myself to do
that
too if the firearm should
sound please leave the meeting room by
following the fire exit signs and meet
on the IP toown football club training
pitch do not re-enter the building until
you're told it is safe to do so finally
we will be using EV voting for this
meeting on the modern. goov app so
please can members make sure they are
logged in in and ready to use the
app I'd like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to consented to being filmed by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
will also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those images and sound recordings for
webcast in and or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
Press May record film or photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully
excluded so can I welcome everyone uh
Council uh cabinet members and officers
for coming along this morning and we'll
move to the agenda item one is apologies
for absence thank you chair there are no
apologies
received item two to receive
Declarations of pecuniary other
registrable or
non-registered authority the monitoring
officer has granted dispensations to all
members and that includes twin Hatters
and company directors in respect of the
2425 budget papers are there any other
Declarations of
Interest now we'll move on to item three
this is paper MCA stroke 23 stroke 41 to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on the 9th of January
2024 um are there any points regarding
the accuracy of the minutes and I just
note that um somehow councelor Whitehead
was left off the list of attendees and
we've amended that thank you
John any other uh points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes it's not about
the accuracy and this may not be the
right time but did we agree about having
minutes and actions from cabinet
meetings and having a separate actions
section oh you've got me there um well
can I put it the other way can we do
that going
forward okay uh thank you chair uh we do
actually have an action uh art of the
cabinet meeting which member can access
via the teams link um that's a bit
embarrassing for you to tell me updated
every time after the cabinet meeting so
we do have an action sheet and we do
have the minutes um okay I wasn't aware
of that but that doesn't come through
the formal papers at all h no it doesn't
come through the formal
papers good we cleared that up then we
have an action sheet and we uh is
accessible though not in the public
domain um so can I have a proposal for
the minutes
please councilor eburn and
seconder councelor Weller and I will ask
now ask the governor's officer to
conduct the
vote thank you chair that vote is now in
progress sorry well uh my laptop's just
restarted itself so um I'm affirmative
on that one thanks thank
you uh thank you members that is six
votes for that's
unanimous thank you so the minutes are
agreed and I will sign them at the end
of the
meeting so we move on to item four uh
this is to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition
scheme none
received uh item five questions by
counselors none received item six
matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committees there are no matters referred
chair thank you uh and then item seven
is the forthcoming decisions list which
is there are there any comments on the
forthcoming decisions
list
no okay thank
you so we move on to the substantive
items for the meeting item eight is
paper MCA stroke 23 stroke 42 uh the
general fund budget
2425 and the four-year Outlook and we
have various officers here to support uh
this item Karen Watling who's the deputy
section5 officer an interim corporate
manager I think he joining us on the
hybrid
link um and we have alist Greer and Mike
Hurst
no have I to agree here yeah great okay
so I'll now invite the cabinet member
for finance and resources to introduce
the rip pole councelor EA um thank you
very much chair um I'm pleased to
present the general fund budget for 2425
and the four-year Outlook um first I'd
like to start by thanking officers for
all their work on this it's a huge
amount of work that's gone into this and
not just producing the figures that you
see but really thinking about and
interrogating the processes Behind these
figures checking back into the finance
modeling the expert advice provided the
alignment across all
services we as a Cabinet have spent a
lot of time going through the finances
and covering a variety of issues many
result of the lack of challenge in the
past and yet we've still bought our off
opposition colleagues in to discuss
matters around the
budget however there's still more work
to be done we need to re visit the
long-term Financial strategy noting that
this report only includes an Outlook and
again this is something that we'll
involve opposition group leaders in as
it's important for the council and we
believe in working through
consensus um but today we have in front
of us the proposed budget for the coming
Financial year and this green
Administration wishes to provide quality
services to Residents and businesses in
inv in the district for the future while
exercising Good Financial Management in
the long term this means ensuring the
finances are secure despite a really
significant drop in Government funding
over the years while investing in the
district so that our communities are
thriving and more resilient socially
environmentally and economically we are
not looking at cutting costs for the
sake of it nor investing in areas beyond
our remit nor running the council like a
corporation but working with businesses
and communities as an important and
valued local government
organization this budget is about doing
something about taking responsibility
about spending taxpayers money wisely
it's about working with our communities
to achieve a really great great place to
live and
work so this proposed budget for 2425
takes into account the rising costs
affected by inflation and interest rates
increased count for tax receipts due to
an increased
population recent increases in business
rates and reductions in Government
funding and I also note that we've had
some last minute change changes of which
there are some table papers and on top
of this as we didn't receive some
government figures until late Monday
there are new amounts for Rural Services
delivery Grant and funding guarantee
which is a total of £120,000 of income
on top of the um revised information in
the table tabled
papers
so in order to ensure that we have
robust financial management and can
deliver high quality services over the
next decade we are recommending
increasing council tax by
2% mids suffix portion of a households
council tax is about 8 to 9% and over
the next few years to keep income in
line with Rising costs it's necessary to
factor in this small council tax rise we
have seen in other councils in suffer
what happens over time when this is not
done unpalatable cuts to important
services we also know that central
government is planning changes at some
point to business rates and this has the
potential to seriously impact our
funding we need to plan for the next
decade with a robust Financial strategy
and with this longer term view we're
investing in our communities with a
capital program that will meet the green
administration's priorities ensuring
environmental and social
responsibilities are at the heart of
everything that we
do we will have a capital program that
invests in new foot and cycling paths
housing for those most in need in
ensuring everyone has access to a green
space in land for biodiversity and in
our vibrant Town centers we've already
put some of this into practice with a
home insulation scheme grants for
Community Bus Services greater
consultation with communities support
with PL flooding and plans for improved
biodiversity we want to work with our
communities with our local businesses
with everyone at the council to provide
quality services in this thriving
landscape that mids deserves and with
that chair I'd like to move the
recommendations on page 15 of the papers
that's recommendations 3.1 to 3.4 and
I'd ask for a seconder thank you very
much thank you councilor abben I'm happy
to second from the chair and I'll just
make a few comments now
um I'm happy to Second these budget
proposals uh and can I say I'm extremely
grateful to councelor eurn I think we
all are for the work she's put in in the
prep ation of the budget also to the
officers involved in the process I'm
aware it's been a hard slog and there is
still more to do um some refinements and
extra information needed before the the
the budget comes to for Council on the
22nd any budget is in some ways a best
guess looking a year or more ahead we
can do as much planning and forecasting
as possible so that we have allowed for
various
eventualities but we can't foresee the
future and it's seems to me that the
year ahead contains a number of
uncertainties which could very well
affect the council's finances and whilst
our general fund is currently in a
healthy position and I acknowledge We
inherited a favorable finances from the
previous
administration that could change with
one stroke of a Minister's pen so we do
need to be prudent and think further
ahead when the financial picture may not
be so
Rosy I made a quick list of potential
changes which could impact the council's
finances uh we know we're going to have
a general election sometime in the next
few months uh and that could result in
change in government policy a business
rates Baseline reset would have a
significant impact on us as would a fair
funding
review a change in government policy on
freep ports could impact us and then we
have an uncertain global economic
situation there's war in Ukraine
conflict in the Middle East uh and one
of the world's busiest trade routes
under attack if things got worse there
it could have a negative impact on the
global economy to which we are all
connected and lastly we're already
starting to see the impact of changes in
the accounting rules around minimum
Revenue provision so in this context the
proposal to raise council tax by 2%
seems a reasonable one we have the
opportunity to raise it by
2.99% inflation is currently at 4% so
anything below that is in fact a real
terms decrease the costs of providing
our services have increased
substantially and a 2% rise is therefore
a reasonable compromise there's a small
increase which could avoid the need to
raise by higher amounts in subsequent
years we will still be receiving roughly
nine p in every pound of council tax
paid and using that to provide a wide
range of services to Residents this is
very good value and I'm therefore happy
to Second the budget
proposals
now is there any questions from cabinet
members on the budget
paper councelor winch um the the
additional paper has got the uh amount
the MP amount related to CCO is 538 can
I ask two questions one is what is the
total amount of the Deferred loan that
the 538 relates to uh and the second
question it came up at a meeting the
other day and I read realize it's my
understanding but with the
MRP I probably shouldn't ask it at this
meeting but do we actually pay that to
the government what happens to it what
how does how does that actually
function c um I was going to ask alist
I'm not sure if you can answer the
question about the cifco first
point uh yes hello bear with me I'm
relatively new to the council so still
very much getting up to speed um I I I
believe the
mids uh portion of the load to cifco I I
believe
uh actually I'm I'm I'm not sorry I'm
not not confident about that figure can
I get back to you on that Alis sorry
I'll ask if Emily um the director for
assets Investments can help because um
on the CF go
Point thank you um so the Deferred
amount of loan um or loan defer for
mider um is around about £400,000
um the ecl calculation is a bit more
technical it doesn't just look at the
amount of the deferrals it looks at a
number of other factors um and looks at
probability so the
537,500 URS the ecl is a a technical
calculation that looks at a number of
different scenarios it's not um a direct
relationship with the um amount of
deferred uh debt to be repaid um but we
can take you through the calculation but
probably not not in this
meeting risk as a shall I answer the
second part of the question counselor
yeah yes
please yeah no um the MRP doesn't go
back to central government what it does
it's a charge to the revenue budget so a
charge to our Council
taxpayers and then what happens to that
charge it's a it credits the amount of
indebtedness we actually hold as a
council um so in that way it's sort of
it's sort of reducing the amount of debt
we
hold um and that that's the way it works
so it goes back into the count so but in
order to reduce the amount of debt we
hold if that makes
sense okay has that answered your
questions councelor Wich thank you thank
you yeah any further questions from
cabinet
members no okay so any questions from
other members present um councelor scarf
first uh thank you chairman um page 24
refers to the reduction of 232,000
in the interest income budget received
by the council from its lending to cfco
limited and was shown in the January 24
overview scrutiny committee report this
reduction has been reversed in the
figures including in this report
following the completion of budget
forecasting work by CCO limited and
their advisors um can I ask what has
changed between January 24 when uh it
came to overview in scrutiny and now
perhaps you give us a little bit more
clarity on that thank thank you um thank
you for that um councilor scarf I'll ask
um Emily if she can provide a detailed
answer to that thank
you thank you councelor so sff Co have
been undertaking some detailed cash flow
work um with our advisers um and that
piece of work has been completed um over
the last few weeks um which has been um
forecasting forward the income that
we're expected to receive from cifco um
over the next um
uh next financial year um with uh
continuing uh improved uh debt
collection levels um and income growth
uh within the portfolio uh CCO is now
projecting that they will be in a
position to make full debt repayments in
uh the next financial
year councelor scarf a sort of
subsidiary question to that then um my
understanding was CCO was was going to
uh be quite ambitious in its targets
with EPC ratings uh and getting them all
up to a C and or even B does this have
any effect on the portfolio's ability to
maintain that drive for improved EPC
ratings or
not so uh CCO continues to have an
ambitious um program in terms of
improving the sustainability of its
portfolio looking at the capital
expenditure required for the next
financial year um it's not as great as
it has been in previous years that's
largely due to the um the lease expires
that are coming in next year lowering
the uh capital expenditure needed for
refurbishments during that year we still
have a program um to deliver EPC
improvements but continue to work with
our tenants and actually are finding
that a number of our um improvements are
being tenant Le so with the support of
the landlord lot of them are actually
being funded by the the tenants so no
there isn't any impact in 2425 in terms
of our EPC program from making full debt
repayments council whad do you have any
questions yes thank you chair um most of
my questions on numbers have been
answered by the um uh Finance team at
our opposition briefing so I thank them
for that but um on the new tabled papers
on page three and I'm going to I'm going
to refer to the sort of wording there so
probably useful if people can sort of
see in front of them to make it more
clear so that's
page yeah I'm sorry
page page three of the table
papers oh okay as I us okay right page
three of the tabled papers um I've got
question relates to sections four and
five and I asked a question because not
only does this come before counselors
but it's goes the general public can
read this so I think it's important it's
understandable so section four says um
what's proposed mids suffer an increase
in council tax of 2% and then section
five says why and the answer is to be
able to produce a balanced budget I mean
given that Surplus is over 5 million and
council tax increase only accounts of
140,000 of that I mean does council even
feel that is a true and fair statement
to make in the for the general public to
read that's my first
question the second question it goes on
and says if we freeze council tax
increases then even where a surplus
exists the gap between income and
expenditure will only become wider well
where a surplus exists a gap between
income and expenditure becomes wider is
actually an increased Surplus so that's
actually a nonsense statement there so
if that wording could be changed before
it goes to to full Council my third
question is just in section four why why
they need to even show bab's information
when no other councils is shown that's
my three questions then on
that um thank you councelor um Whitehead
um yes we do need to produce a balanced
budget um and the
um the Surplus is being used for um
Investments within the district um so is
not being used for um core
services so you're happy with that
wording um we well we'll revisit the
wording but um to double check but that
that is the case thank you and then
sorry then one just one technical
question on page nine and it's actually
following up for what council winch
asked paragraph 311 refers to voluntary
M MRP payment year end perhaps the
finance team could uh advise whether
that is a payment or just a provision
because again I think the wording needs
to be
accurate um I think that um Council
thank you Council WAD for your question
that's referring to the the payment into
the budget as it were kind of thing
that's the you
know the budget needs to make the
payment so so it's not a cash payment
which although might read as such it's
provision it's a yeah an accounting
entry rather than a
payment yeah just to comment on on the
on the the previous question on page
three um appears to me that that paper
refers to both councils so it's trying
to um capture two while quite widely
differing situations and perhaps is a
little bit um struggling to do that so I
think you're right it does need a little
bit of revision just to sort of make
that clear
yeah chair if I if I may maybe we for
the for Full Count for the when the
budget papers go to the council we'll do
one that's specifically just um for Bas
they can do theirs and we'll do one
specifically for for ours because then
it'll make it
clearer any further
questions uh clearly we'll have the
opportunity to debate this in full
Council when it comes in a couple of
weeks time um but in terms of uh cabinet
we have an opportunity to debate this
item now uh who would like to make a
contribution to the
debate councilor winch thank you um okay
just to reiterate the thanks that's all
already been given thank you very much
for the officers and to Rachel for
getting us to to this position I've
written three things down on on this on
my bit of paper in front of me the first
thing I probably shouldn't say but we're
a new we're a new Council I'm new to
council processes I find the budget
process a bit bewildering we've already
talked about how late in the year it
happens and I I know there's plans to
have a look at that I also find it
strange that we operate a budget process
that's a little bit independent from the
business planning process and I think
we've all felt frustrations around this
and I think that next year we'll get
that a fair bit tighter um on this issue
of council tax and charges when you've
got a a large Surplus this is always a
tricky debate but I think we've got this
about right and that is as a new new
green Administration we want to make a
big impact we plan to spend some of our
reserves and have an impact on the
districts but we need to leave the
council finances in a state that are
good for the long term so we need to be
thinking 5 10 years ahead not just one
or two years so I think putting cancel
tax up not by the maximum but by 2% is
sensible and starting to bring some of
our charges more into line with the cost
base is also
sensible um I think finally what what is
this budget about the really good news
for Mid suffk is that our general fund
is in a very good State and that gives
us a really strong basis for moving
forward on a lot of the priorities that
we have um and I think that's our
message to the residents is up to us us
to get on and deliver the priorities and
and live up to the Mandate that we were
given thank you councelor winch uh
anyone else councelor Stringer yeah
thank you chair I like to U again thank
the officers for all their time and
diligence in going through us and
actually like to personally thank the
portfolio holder for her diligence and
all of the opposition counselors for you
looking into the vast amount of detail
and screeds of of of forms and figures
and tables we've had to look at um the
on the issue of uh why would you raise
council tax a small amount while you
have a budget surplus
that the the the easy way would be to
take that budget surplus and just
suggest that we can carry on and not
raise taxes or even cut taxes um of
course the problem you then get is is is
the problem a certain other Council has
that sits in this particular chamber
where it is it has tried to do that over
the years and now this year they are
having to raise taxes as much as they
possibly can while having huge cuts to
some of their services so I I think this
Council would seek to avoid that at all
all terms and to achieve that what you
really need to get to is a very very
sensible balanced year on-year
position uh where where this council's
finances can wash its face each year
which is why we've taken some of those
steps to make sure that each of the
areas of service that we carry out is
covering its cost uh and sometimes that
means we have to charge those service
users a little bit more for that uh but
I think if we can get this Council onto
that kind of footing that means that
when we do get surpluses we need to get
that money out there working on those
other projects that then moves this
Council on and truly achieves uh the
huge success that we think the people of
been suffer can achieve thank you
chair thank you very much um any other
contributions Council
aurn um thank you very much um chair I
just wanted to kind of finish off really
by saying that one of the things that we
need to look at in the future um as into
the very near future is the medium-term
financial strategy and a long-term
Financial strategy
um and we're starting having those
discussions now and I kind of want to
reiterate the point that I'd like to
ensure that the um opposition group
leaders are involved in those
discussions because I think it's really
really important that we all have a kind
of complete um wide view of the of the
long-term future particularly
potentially with um issues such as
Government withdrawing or completely
changing rather how business rates is
calculated and and this Council
therefore losing um a lot of the
business r ratees income and on that
note I'd say as well that the the one of
the reasons for the Surplus in this
current budget is that we had set aside
um as we're required to do an amount for
business rate appeals and the time frame
for um accessing that has ended and so
of of that we've had 2.4 million that
we'd set aside that we thought we may
need to use for appeals and that has
gone now back into the budget so what
we'd be looking at now as an
Administration is is getting that um
funding back out there to um serve our
communities and businesses and um really
ensure we can make an impact with it but
I'd hope that everybody um can support
this this budget today thank you
chair thank you very much uh so if no
further debate I will read out the
recommendations and then we'll move to
the vote so the recommendations are 3.1
that the general fund budget proposals
for 2024 stoke 25 and fouryear Outlook
set out in the report comprising the
revenue and capital estimates as well as
the proposed movements and reserves be
endorsed for recommendation to Council
on 22nd of February
2024 that 3.2 that currently the general
fund budget for 2024 Stoke 25 presented
in this report assumes a 2% increase in
the band D council tax and that this is
endorsed for recommendation to
council 3.3 that as at the time of
writing this report three budget items
are not yet final estimates namely
financing costs paragraph
5.12 costs arising from likely
regulatory changes in accounting for
learning payments paragraph 5.14 and
final Grant income figures from central
government paragraph 5.19 officers will
aim to table final es to um to council
assume that means at this meeting for
endorsement is that correct it says
cabinet but I think it probably means
Council yeah uh 3.4 that the new income
banss and contribution rates for the 20
24 Stoke 25 100% local council tax
recommend reduction working age scheme
as set out in paragraph 5.29 be endorsed
for recommendation to council and then
from the table papers uh we endorse the
recommendation to council the recreation
of an expected credit loss reserve of
$538,000 as explained in paragraphs 3.4
3.11 to be funded by using some of the
2024 stroke 25 forecast Surplus in the
revenue budget for this
purpose so those are the recommendations
and I will now ask the governor's
officer to conduct the
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress
thank you members that's six votes for
that's
unanimous thank you uh we move on to
item nine uh this is paper MCA 23
st43 the housing revenue account HRA 24
25 budget uh and we still have um Karen
wling the deputy section 151 officer and
interim corporate manager Finance
commissioning and procurement online uh
Jenny Smithy who's the finance business
partner for HR revenue is here and I
will now invite the cabinet member for
finance resources to introduce the
report
thank you very much chair I'm pleased to
present the housing revenue account
budget
2425 and again I'd like to thank start
by thanking officers for their their
work on this it's a huge amount of work
has been done in a real interrogation of
these finances has taken
place um this has uncovered a variety of
issues some easily solvable and some not
so and certainly not the financially
robust position we were led to believe
we were in
inheriting um the house housing revenue
account um or H is a ring fenced account
from which all aspects of counsil
housing are manag and finance and
alongside this a 30-year business plan
um as required is being produced
together with a full survey of the
council's property and this will provide
a basis for future decisions it's vital
to us as a green Administration that we
carefully manage this account as this is
our responsibility to our more than
3,300 tenants we want to ensure that
they have safe secure environmentally
efficient homes and while the council
owns these properties every single
property is someone's
home in order to ensure that we have the
funds for the upkeep of these homes
we're proposing rents are increased in
line with government
recommendations we are acutely aware of
the increases in the cost of living and
how many people are struggling dayto day
but with the increase in housing related
benefits we hope that the majority of
our tenants will not be out of pocket
however we if we don't do this some of
our services will be at
risk we also have in place and plans to
boost initiatives to help those
vulnerable tenants in need and with much
central government help being cut we
will be doing our bit as local
government to provide our residents with
the support that they
deserve we must ensure that we keep our
that we can afford sorry to keep our
tenants homes well maintained during The
Current financial year we've effectively
had to pay for two years of housing
repairs in one as well as deal with a
multipe of compliance issues however I'm
pleased to say that despite an extremely
tight budget we will have the ability to
improve the environmental efficiency of
many of these homes subject to getting
match funding and this will ensure homes
are easier to heat and therefore save on
bills too we also want to continue to
invest in housing for residents of mids
suffk we have an ambitious program of
acquisition and new builds within the
limits of the constrain finances and we
must deliver low carbon homes that that
are secure and low maintenance we must
ensure our tenants have the best homes
that we can provide and that we continue
to invest in these meeting their needs
and the
districts so I'm with that chair I'd
like to propose the recommendations on
page 48 of the papers that's
recommendations 4.1 to 4.5 and a look
for a seconder thank you
chair thank you council do we have a
seconder councelor
winch yeah I'm I'm very happy to Second
this um I think the clarity of the
report is I'm really pleased with and
its transparency I'm really pleased with
the numbers I I don't like at all so I
think whoever is responsible for the HRA
is extremely difficult because it is a
basically a dysfunctional system so the
the council um tenants have to pay for
the repairs and maintenance of their
properties fair enough but they also
have to pay for the decarbonization of
the properties new build of council
houses in the district
servicing a debt which is now 24% of the
total income and they also have within
that Cate for the impact the right to
buy scheme that is a completely Bonker
system um we have inherited a bit of a
mess here I would say we've got a poor
service with relatively limited funds to
go forward that doesn't mean that there
aren't things we can do and I would say
there are three major things going on at
the moment the biggest is is the housing
transformation project which is looking
in detail at repairs and maintenance
trying to make us a lot more efficient
and give a much better service to our
Council
tenants um we're also doing everything
we can do to get in grant funding so the
the current we currently applied for the
social housing decarbonization fund so
any grant funding that's available we
need to try and latch on to and we will
be doing a detailed review of all the
capital items that are in the HRA at the
moment just to make sure they all pay
their way um I think going forward I I
am a little bit nervous maybe I'm not
allowed to say this in a public forum
but I would like to see us having and
now I know we've got an action log I'd
like to see these on the action log um I
would like a much better advanced
warning or approval Andor approval
process of anything that's going to go
outside these parameters because I now
think we've hit the point where where we
can't go outside those numbers because
we're starting to eat too far into our
reserves and I'm not entirely satisfied
that we've got that in place at the
moment um um that's all I wanted to
say thank you councilor winch um do we
have any questions from cabinet members
on this
report if not any questions from other
counselors councelor scar
thank you
chairman um one of the recommendations
obviously is the increase in cheetwood
housing service charges um so my
question sort of cover that area um does
the proposed increase Now cover the true
cost over the range of sheltered homes
that we have for the service charges
finally because we always know um
historically it hasn't and this is
obviously an attempt to equalize the
situation um and supplementary to that
uh you mentioned the government's
decarbonization fund are we going to as
a coun do everything we can to mitigate
those service charge increases for those
sheltered housing scheme residents I.E
um solar panels Etc whatever we can do
to decarbonize the stock which we would
be doing to other stock in in our
general uh housing stock because I feel
there's a moral duty that we now ought
to look to um the sheltered housing
schemes to do everything we can to help
those residents in the future to
mitigate any massive increases in
service charges thank
you um I think thank thank you for that
that councel scarf I think for the
sheltered housing schemes we're kind of
getting there in terms of costs I think
one of the areas that we need to look at
um over in the next what we are planning
to be looking at as it were is the
shelter Ed schemes full stop and how
they're sort of arranged and funded and
so on so that's sort of piece of work
that's kind of ongoing as it were um but
it is an and as you know it's all it
always has been an issue in terms of
um meeting kind of the full cost of that
scheme so that is something we're
looking at with with regards I'll let
Council winch comment on that as well
but with regards to the
um improving sort of the environmental
efficiency of of homes you'll see that
in the capital budget there's a
1.8 million amount in there and that's
the amount that we would would hope to
get a um funding match funding from
government on in order to do that and I
think we then want to be just be doing
what we can to look for other sources as
it were to to improve that for for
tenants Council M do you want to come
well yeah other than I'm not going to
directly answer I think it's a good
question question I believe that we
fully recover the the cost now but I we
don't not
yet sorry um not yet it's an ongoing
project at the moment these are the
costs that we know are relating to the
sheltered accommodation but we are
currently looking at the costs which are
not necessarily coded sheltered
accommodation but relate to sheltered
accommodation to make sure that they are
captured for the future okay and the
other thing is to re s um what council
Ean said there's a general review going
on of shelter which will bring into
issues that you've raised about um you
know do we do we need solar panels
Etc any further questions coun scar
Council whad no questions from you okay
so we can move to debate on this
item um anyone like to contribute to
debate councelor Stringer yeah thank you
chair um housing Revenue accounts uh
yeah and Absolut not if if we were
designing a way of funding Council
housing I I don't think in our wildest
dreams would come up with a with a
system like we've got at the moment
because it doesn't seem to help those
that are trying to deliver it or or
those that are in receipt of it um and
and actually I think even even those
within government are now spotting that
I mean I don't normally look for radical
ideas on a website called conservative
home but a counselor from suffk called
Colin Noble has just written a piece
about h on conservative home basically
laying out that you have to get local
authorities into a financial sustainable
position within H if we are going to
even deliver our commercial housing
targets so there is even now a
recognition uh among those that perhaps
wouldn't be as sympathetic to social
housing as you might might think they
would be politically are now recognizing
that we have to address the systemic
issues of the housing revenue account
how does that help us with setting it
right now it doesn't help a great deal
to think there might be changes in the
system later because we have to set the
budget for this year and because of the
constraints of the mechanisms the only
way we can make this account more
financially sustainable is to either
carry out less work on our stock which
is unsustainable in all sorts of ways or
or or to uh uh raise the amount of money
coming into that account and the only
way of raising that amount of money into
that account is to affect the rents
which we equally wouldn't want to do but
we have to put this budget into a
financial sustainable position or at
least attempt to U uh while we await
government changes uh and plead with
them to to to make those changes that
will make that job all the easier um so
I would also call I mean I will vote for
this but obviously heavy heart because
it is not a position I I would certainly
want us to be in but equally say at all
speed to anyone of any political
persuasion that's asking the government
to change and reform uh housing Revenue
accounts of local for housing providers
because it needs to be changed if not we
are going to end up in a cycle of of
where uh tenants are going to be
expected to pay more and more each
coming year purely just to keep our head
above War thank you ch
thank you councel Stringer uh any
further contributions to the
debate coun
eurn thank you chair just just to come
back on this report excuse me the um you
know we mentioned at the beginning the
amount of work that the finance team
have done on this which is which is
incredible but also the housing team
them themselves and all the people
involved in that there's a a lot of
projects going on a lot of work looking
at how um it this the system can become
much more efficient but also while
providing those really you know good
quality Council homes that
are you know can be easily heated as it
were rather than um rather than not and
that have got a safe and secure for
people to to call to live in and call
their home so we do need to be you know
it is like Council Stringer said with a
heavy heart and were saying to um
recommend to increase rents but we have
to put the money in to make sure those
homes are
are become sustainable for the long-term
future and it's not something that I
would you know want to be doing but um
you know until government changes the
rules unfortunately we have we have no
option at this point in time so we look
forward to kind of you know working to
try to improve the situation here in
making our homes the best they can be
for our tenants um and hopefully those
people that and and also those people
that might need our help and assistance
we will have measures in place to
support them in that thank you
J thank you K Le um I'll just make a
couple of comments from the chair then
before we move to the recommendations
and the vote so clearly this is quite a
sobering report to read uh we are
between a rock and a hard place in terms
of
the uh the sustainability the financial
sustainability of the H account um we
would not want to be uh
increasing uh Council of house rents to
this extent but we are in a position of
needing to as as my colleagues have have
set out and clearly two things would be
very helpful one is any opportunity
members or officers have to Lobby
government to change the rules so that
um we could we could do better with this
situation would be good uh and the other
thing is as Council Stringer said you
know some uh radical ideas to uh change
how we do things with this account um we
are I think open to any suggestions um
in order to move things forward in a
more sustainable
Direction but now I will read out the
recommendations and we will move to the
vote so the recommendation is 4.1 that
the HRA budget proposals for 2024 stke
25 set out in the report be endorsed for
recommendation to Council on 20 22nd of
February
2024 4.2 that an increase of 7.7% for
Council house rents equivalent to an
average rent increase of
£7.33 a week for social rent and an RPI
of plus
.5% that's 99.4% in total increase for
an affordable rent of £165 a week be
implemented 4.3 that the RPI increase of
88.9% in garage rents equivalent to an
average rent increase of £384 a month be
implemented 4.4 that an increase of 18%
for sheltered housing service charges
equivalent to 2719 a month be
implemented and 4.5 that an increase of
44% for sheltered housing utility
charges equivalent to £29 63 p a month
be implemented I will now ask the
governance officer to conduct the
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress thank you members that's votes
for that's carried chair thank
you uh that concludes the business of
the meeting clearly we'll be revisiting
these issues again in a couple of weeks
time at the full council meeting just to
remind you that the next meeting uh the
date has changed it's been moved to
Monday the 4th of March at 9:30 a.m. it
will be here in the chamber and it's
been moved because of the chamber
availability uh but apart from that I
declare the meeting closed thank you for
coming